A Washington Post article,
November,
2016 and it said out of the 700 counties in Pennsylvania,
Ohio,
um,
Wisconsin that voted for Obama twice,
predominantly white counties,
a third of them flipped and voted for president Trump.
So the racism argument just doesn't wash because if you vote in a black man
twice for president,
uh,
especially in Ohio,
I think where there was 37 counties that voted,
uh,
predominantly white,
that voted President Obama in twice.
And then they flipped and turned to Ohio.
And I've been raising the red flag on this for a long time.
I've been saying to people that I really believe that president Trump's victory,
he's ill equipped to be president.
We all know that.
He has no clue what he's doing was an absolute a signal that the regressive
left.
This had driven people crazy and insane and they were frustrated and fed up,
um,
for being called bigoted.
They were sick of being talked down to and then
still being talked down to like the,
the classic response of the mainstream media to,
to the existence of Trump is to basically assume 50% of the American electorate
are stupid racist bigots.
Like Hillary called them deplorables.
The basket of deplorables.
Yeah.
But you know what,
I've been actually kind of looking at what the grievances are and what the
concerns are and do you sound like really decent people to me would,
they're asking real questions about unvetted immigration,
large amounts of immigration to the country,
border security,
uh,
millions of illegal immigrants.
They're asking very real questions that would concern anybody and for that
they're being labeled bigoted and racist.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it is in it.
That's the sort of thing that's driving this dangerous polarization and it's,
it's really,
it's really unfortunate.
Yeah.
And my concern is,
and my concern ever since Trump has been elected is that we're going to create a
toxic environment in Canada because from the universities and colleges we can
already see it's there that we are going to drive people in Canada to very
radical fringe positions.
And that's my worry.
Well,
if we elect wouldn't again then we'll certainly be well on the road to doing
that.
And I also think that the Trudeau government is far to the left of where people
originally assumed it would be.
I mean,
I think that his decision to put 50% women in the cabinet was an abdication of
responsibility on the magnitude that,
that we haven't seen before in Canadian political history.
Only 26% of the of the MPs elected were female and that should have been
approximately the proportion of cabinet members.
But to say this is 2015 or whatever the hell the year.
And then to abdicate his responsibility for selecting the most competent people
was an an indication of exactly how,
uh,
what would you say how suited he is to be prime minister and people just didn't
make much of an issue of that because of their attempts to be tolerant.
But I think that what he did was re,
oh,
I thought the fact that he ran to begin with was reprehensible because he ran
entirely on the name brand recognition that he had derived from his father.
And I think that that's the mark of someone who's narcissistic.
You shouldn't have done that
for him.
Very charismatic and attractive,
and he knows how to behave in public.
And so Andy had a very,
very famous name and,
but I believe that it was immoral of him to run because the,
we're not dynasties,
democracies aren't dynasties,
and he hadn't the,
um,
the CV,
the,
the record of success that you would need as an independent individual to
justify himself as a qualified candidate for prime minister.
So I thought that is his candidacy right from the start was ethically flawed
then to,
to multiply that error with these,
these,
uh,
shallow attempts at broadcasting tolerance,
especially at the expense of competence and the capacity to truly evaluate is
just inexcusable.
Inexcusable.